bonsoir j'ai calé on me emile merci
d'être avec nous on voit ces quatre
policiers donc lors d'une tués lors
d'une opération dans un quartier
contrôlé par un gain par les gangs
qu'elle est aujourd'hui l'influencent de
ces gangs en haïti immense l'affluence
influence de ces gangs d'une part
soutenu par des politiques qui sait qui
sont les bras armé est certaine de
certains hommes politiques
on parle même du président de la
république lui même tout au moins de son
entourage et puis il est même les les
les hommes d'affaires les entrepreneurs
n'hésite pas à se servir de ses gains
notamment pour éliminer la concurrence
voilà ces gones sont là ils sont odieux
qui sont destitution analyser comment
expliquer qu'on n'arrive pas à lutter
davantage contre ce phénomène
je vous ai donné une partie de la
réponse
si un gang était si les gones sont les
bras armé des responsables politiques
d'un côté si de l'autre quand il ya une
opération comme celle qui a coûté la vie
à quatre policiers et qui a fabriqué et
qui a vu la veille huit autres blessés
c'est dû à quoi
parce qu'il ya une corruption tels que
parmi les forces d'intervention
il y a je dirais dlsi des espions la
police est infiltré par les gants donc
quand il s'agit d'argent eh bien on
dénonce et on dénonce ces opérations qui
vont avoir lieu donc la police arrive
elle est entendue
le bureau des nations unies en haïti a
affirmé qu'il était impératif qu'on
trouve les coupables que ses auteurs
soient arrêtés poursuivis traduits
devant la justice
si on vous comprend bien jacques léon
emile cet objectif n'est pas vraiment
réalisable parce qu'il s'agit encore une
fois de voeux pieux sauvées chaque fois
qu'il ya une situation en haïti se sait
c'est quand même ce qu'il ya de
révoltant c'est que quand il ya une
situation des déséquilibres comme ça en
haïti qu'est-ce qu'on
en temps ou bien en avoir balance des
mots de sympathie et puis d'aidé en
évoquant convoque les grandes phrases
pour dire ça n'a pas le droit d'avoir
lieu ce n'est pas normal
et puis la troisième la troisième
proposition on finit par diers vous
savez ces haïtiens ne sont pas capables
de se gérer
on sait aujourd'hui tout le monde le
sait que la solution ne pas ne peut pas
se régler entre haïtiens uniquement
regardez ce qui se passe quand même dans
le monde
je vais vous citer quatre cas il ya des
manifestations de rue à wang comme qui
bénéficient de la delà de la sympathie
médiatique le venezuela
la réponse a été un blocus la birmanie
des sanctions contre les militaires
le liban il ya un ultimatum en fait une
mise en demeure qui avait fait aux
dirigeants aux hommes politiques à la
classe politique libre et libanais ni
malaise que dit-on d'haïti il faut que
les choses se fassent
il faut que là il faut que le que les
élections se déroulent dans la paix
jacques lerrant emile comment vous
expliquer cette indifférence
pardonnez-moi mais comment vous
ce silence assourdissant des communauté
internationale concernant votre pays
j'aimerais pouvoir vous l'expliquer
autrement que de vous dire que
historiquement le monde occidental
européens et nord américains
plus précisément les etats-unis ont mis
haïti en réserve
il ya une discrimination racisme
vis-à-vis d'haïti ce n'est pas pour
jouer la victime que je le dis ce n'est
pas non plus pour entrer pour entrer
dans un débat dans une polémique
quelconque c'est historique c'est
historique
voilà haïti est un mauvais exemple dans
deux sens et je m'en tiens qu'un sale je
pourrais développer des heures a été un
mauvais exemple entre guillemets bien
sûr pour avoir été un pays une bonne
d'esclaves à avoir battu la plus grande
puissance du monde de l'époque la france
ça ça ne se pardonne pas
la deuxième cause c'est que haïti est
demeuré un mauvais exemple pour les
noirs américains les esclaves noirs en
banque
je vous rappelle quand même
historiquement haïti est indépendante en
1804 et que le l'esclavagé est aboli aux
états unis 1865
elles se sont claires comme ça haïti est
une jeune et malgré tout vous voyez que
les haïtiens moi je suis en france le
vit correctement jeu et comme plusieurs
d'autres plusieurs autres haïtiens qui
vivent à l'étranger
ce n'est pas une paranoïa de l'haïtien
c'est un constat historique
haïti n'a pas de pétrole haïti n'a rien
qui intéresse la population mondiale et
en plus ça y tient un passé qui a
dérangé les grandes puissances et ben ça
continue je peux vous dire l'éducation
je pense qu historiquement elle atteint
discute je pense elle est historique
indiscutable alors la situation
politique est très complexe et instable
ce qui n'arrange évidemment pas des
choses on rappelle le gouvernement de de
jouvenel moïse qui a été jugée
inconstitutionnelle par l'opposition
haïtienne par la plus haute instance
d'ailleurs judiciaire du du pays
pourtant le président moïse fait ensuite
arrêté 23 personnes sont peut-être deux
tentatives de deux coups d'état
comment rétablir la paix et la stabilité
dans le pays dans ces conditions le
président moïse
il est appuyé par les parlers par les et
par les états unis qui approuve s'il
n'approuve pas sinon dénonce oralement
mais ne fait rien qu'est ce que vous
voulez mais il a il a tout pouvoir le
président moïse il a tout pouvoir
vous vous rendez compte que c'est un
homme qui est dans le monde à la fin de
mandat et contester la rue proteste
contre sa présence il a il est en plus
impliqués dans des affaires de
corruption
ils organisent référendum qui est tout à
fait anticonstitutionnelle parce que la
constitution
ne ne prévoit pas ce référendum et ça on
laisse faire jacob oubina compris
effectivement le soutien de joe biden
s'est pourtant et 30 à se mettre
toujours du côté de la morale de la
démocratie on l'a vu dans les premières
semaines de son mandat si j'ose dire et
je les assume un petit peu même donneur
de leçon le président américain est
pourtant il soutient ardemment ce
président moïse avec tout ce que vos
auditeurs de corruption d'arrestations
arbitraires
comment l'expliquer aussi il serait naïf
de croire que c'est pas nous c'est pas
une attitude normale
ce serait naïf de croire que les états
unis c'est la politique américaine
depuis 1915 à vis d'haïti 1915 rire
occuper haïti
ce serait naïf de croire le contraire
c'est un discours d'un côté et le et le
et la tolérance de l'autre la tolérance
du et des mauvais actes voilà je je
résume avec des mots un peu un peu
facile c'est ça la situation donc ne
rêvons pas ne nous faisons pas
d'illusions merci en tout cas jacques
collet ont ému d'avoir été avec nous
avoir exposé la situation en haïti après
la mort de ces quatre policiers lors
d'une nouvelle opération menée dans un
quartier contrôlé par des gangs merci à
vous